let's talk a little bit about coming out
breeding we got us there because
everyone thinks that it's always this
hard horrific difficult thing but I
think there are moments like bree is
mentioning and I most of my moments were
like that did you guys have some cool or
fun coming out moments Joe my parents
were extremely liberal they met in the
Peace Corps
they mentioned gay marriage at their
wedding in like 1971 whoa so when I came
out to my parents I chose Christmas
morning I have a gift for you I like
penis Oh my mother my parents were
really down with it and my mother's
first comment was I just want to be sure
that you have good sex that is mom did
it all right pretty good Hannah what
about you oh yeah you know unfortunately
uh not super good in fact one of the bad
ones but that being said I think that
it's a character-building experience and
there's always something that you can
gain from something like that
I once without a panel speaking on a
panel and the gentleman next to me said
something I'll never forget which is
that even if they don't respect you you
have to give you give them the respect
you deserve and I felt like that was
kind of what you were saying Bree about
you know encounter hate with love and so
yeah I think it's been good I came out
openly in 26 now I guess I was 22 but I
came out to myself when I was like 20
and so that's that's kind of how it's
been yeah do you guys think that we
actually get something special because
we have to deal with this that it makes
you know we have this sort of secret
this this shame thing that when you
finally figure out who you are you end
up with a better sense of self like you
end up getting something really special
you have to give yourself that sense of
self because when you grow up as a
heterosexual person your sexuality is
supported by the predominant culture and
if you turn on a television it's okay to
be who you are it's great to be straight
everything is like you know that's
and courtship is celebrated in fact your
parents are part of that you know your
first date and everything and when
you're gay
not so much much what just suddenly I
think it's such an interesting
occurrence is that when you start coming
out to people and the process of coming
out never really ends you come out every
conversation you're like like oh do you
have a boyfriend
nope and girlfriend actually um but what
I think it's interesting is that people
who love you and you love too will think
that since they didn't know this part of
your personality the other fundamental
aspects of you were going to change I
remember when I came out to my sister
she burst into tears and she was like I
just don't want you to just like become
some like lumberjack lesbian yada yada
yada she's like I like who you are yeah
that's like this is this is nothing to
do with who I am on a superficial level
this you actually look like the last
person on earth who could like hack a
tree down Oh Oh first of all very very
strong oh sorry I've got the shirt on
lumber yeah hello lady here yeah that's
right that's right I feel like I need to
come to your defense Thanks you can hack
a tree with the tiny little Charlie
Brown tree happy father what about you I
was making my mental image of myself
just FYI I think I think my coming out
was actually coming out of my mother
into the world John I think homo
at age about age six when I wanted to be
Billy Idol and be with Susanna Hoffs
that was pretty much a tell to my
parents you know I think I think they
pretty much embraced it and and let me
look like Billy Idol as much as I could
at six years old being a girl in
Connecticut um but you know what my mom
always told me it doesn't matter if
they're purple with stripes as long as
they make you happy and she really
ingrained that in and so I I think I was
actually in coming out and actually sang
it I was more nervous because I felt
stupid like it would be like the
equivalent of like a straight person
being like mom
dad just let you know bringing home a
girl like you know like this I'm
straight it doesn't really have a lot of
weight I want it to be more dramatic
yeah before I get to you guys on this
question I think because we're all
somewhat public figures at some level or
we'd like to believe so at least right
you'd like to believe television
something like Thursday do you guys feel
like you have extra pressure you were on
the real l word and you were sort of
like the hit star of the show where do
you feel extra pressure that you have
you could not let the lesbians - I
cannot let the lesbians down only myself
and my family that's really what
happened no you know I think you kind of
get this sense of being role model I
would probably not like to group myself
into that because I kind of was known as
the entire maybe role model I don't know
but um I think it was just about like
being myself and being comfortable and
showing that and I happen to be gay so
there you go let's do so before I get to
you guys do you guys do you feel the
same thing I mean with the videos that
you put out do you feel like sometimes
it's gonna turn the gays against you
over there you should clean himself up
and you know I mean for me the videos
are the biggest thing I get back on
videos is that people will now who are
now in their 20s feel like your video
helped me come out when I was in the
closet in high school and that was just
me dancing around and Ryan stone jeans
back and forth singing about soccer
practice literally again and again
people like I was home everything else
was weird but I saw you you were tough
you were butch you pushed those guys
around I thought wow I could do that too
I can be gay - yeah I said you can gang
let's see that it makes a huge
difference it's like this reality show
now where I travel a tiny little towns
out in the middle of nowhere and in each
every one of those channels there's a
gay person
there's a town gay and and a lot of them
are featured on the show we have a lot
of gay contestants on the show and it
matters to them if you're in the media
and you're yourself I've got the big
comment I get from a lot of people in
small town says thank you for being
yourself when you see people who are
themselves on television
and it empowers people yeah yeah
visibility and readability like well
yeah you know what I think is this kind
of interesting with that reminded me of
this is I get asked questions all the
time for people that are like why are
gay people like this or why they're gay
be like that like why do all gay men
love show choirs and something ignorant
like that yeah and what I always want to
say back is like there are way more gay
people than you realize
so certain personality types are more
comfortable being themselves sure but
that doesn't mean that the there's not
gay accountants yeah but say you put
your you got you know got it exactly
it's like there's way more gay people
that you realize like my college
roommate said that I was the first gay
person she ever met
and I was like where'd you grow up she's
Long Island I said let's look at your
yearbook we open up the yearbook and I
go go to the girls softball page oh so
she grown up with gay people are all a
lot but she didn't know it it'll be
really different for our children you
know they're gonna grow up in a world
and it's not going to matter your the
your interests and the people that you
fall in love with are not you know
related in a director